it wasn't the outcome the French
government wanted but without a
parliamentary majority it decided to
force its pension reform Bill through
Parliament by decree a controversial
move that infuriated some lawmakers and
left the French prime minister
struggling to be heard
we can't risk seeing 175 hours of
parliamentary debate come to nothing we
can't risk seeing the compromise built
by the two houses dismissed we cannot
risk the future of our pensions this
reform is necessary
the move comes after more than two
months of Street protests and Strikes
against the reform led by France's trade
unions who say it's an erosion of
workers rights they're also angry over
plans to raise the retirement age by two
years to 64. demonstrators who gathered
outside the parliament say they'll
continue to fight
it's also pretty revolting is the fact
that despite the fact that the
government represents a tiny minority
and doesn't even have a majority in the
parliament they are the Constitutional
tools that they can use to force it
through in completely undemocratic
manners but that won't that won't
hinderella resolve to pursue the fight
that's why we're here today and that's
why the fight will continue tomorrow for
forcing a bill through the parliament by
decree is legal under the French
Constitution but it is a course of
action seen by many as a failure of
politics
acting outside the National Assembly
France's hard left leader said the
government didn't care about people
I find it significant and symbolic that
for a hundredth time the government used
a decree to bypass the will of the
people we must coordinate with the
unions and do all we can to have this
law withdrawn
forming the pension system was one of
president
s he
he's outdated costly and unsustainable
for future Generations in the end he
will have succeeded in changing it but
at a cost to his political reputation
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Harris
[Music]